last time another video about gravity I
was trying to get across the gravity
changes depending on where on earth you
are for a few reasons including the
earth not being a sphere and what I
forgot was the competition of rocks but
what you might not know is that gravity
doesn't always point straight down
towards Earth if you're next
thanks lesson if the wedding sets plug
down it really does mean slow down you
can come up by my side don't believe the
people you say you can go down without
Freight don't believe so many says this
isn't actually terrifying and you don't
need to slow down around the corners you
do and if you don't it hurts
never mind gravity is something you
might not have known
injury count road rash in four places
hand strung with metals and significant
damage to my pride
pressing that they don't like I was
saying gravity doesn't always point down
but remember yes
see we can do the whole run brakeless